you
[Music]
the burning of fossil fuels is embedded
in almost everything we do in modern
society it's in the clothes that we wear
it's in the food that we eat it's in how
we get around from one place to another
everything that we do is permeated by
the burning of these fossil fuels which
are then releasing greenhouse gases
notably carbon dioxide into the
atmosphere and that is thereby warming
up the planet and our challenge as
researchers is to try to understand how
do mass public's understand this threat
do they understand the causes do they
understand the impacts and how willing
are they to get engaged personally
Anthony lies ur wits is director of the
Yale project on climate change in a
recent study global warming's six
Americas he found that the public's
perception of climate change falls into
six distinct categories so our work
lately has been really focusing on
trying to understand who are the
different publics within the American
public and what we found is that the
American public does not speak with a
single voice on this issue there are in
fact six very distinct Americas within
America and those groups each respond to
this issue in very different ways for
very different reasons our primary
research thus far has been really to try
to understand where the public is right
now and who these different audiences
are and the first of those is what we
call the alarm it's about 18 percent of
the public these are people who are
absolutely convinced climate change is
happening it's human caused it's a very
serious threat it's happening now
they're already taking action in their
own lives to try to reduce their own
carbon footprint and they're really
hungry to know what's the next thing I
can do this has been called in political
science terms and issue public this is
the part of the public that is the most
mobilized and most engaged with this
with this issue and that's actually a
very large issue public compared to
other issue public's say on gun rights
or pro-choice or pro-life or anti
immigration or Pro immigration I mean
those are all different kinds of issue
publics out there that agitate and
advocate for particular policies the
climate change issue public is actually
larger than most of those other ones and
that's a very surprising and
unrecognized fact the second group
however is what we call the concerned
and that's a full third of the public
thirty-three percent that group believes
climate change is happening that it's
human caused they think it's a serious
problem but they still see this a
distant problem and so they're there
they're concerned about it but they
haven't become personally involved with
the issue the third group is what we
call the cautious and that's about 19
percent of the American public for this
group they're not really sure is it
happening is it not is it human caused
is it natural so they're just
very focused on the issue yet and then
comes a very interesting group that we
call the disengaged this is a group that
is heard of the issue they are familiar
with the term climate change or global
warming but they don't know anything
about it they don't know anything about
the causes they don't know anything
about the impacts they certainly don't
know anything about the potential
solutions so the fifth group that we
found is what we call the doubtful and
it's about eleven percent of the public
for this group they're not really sure
that climate change is happening or not
but they say if it is happening it's
naturally caused it's not a problem it's
not going to impact people ever and thus
they just don't see it as much of a risk
at all and then last comes the group
that we call the dismissive and this is
about 7% of the public and for them not
only is it that they believe climate
change isn't happening
but they think it's a hoax or that it's
a conspiracy it's a very small group of
the public on the other hand it's a very
motivated part of the public despite
these fundamental differences Americans
say they support investments in
alternative energy we also find other
policies in particular energy related
policies that everybody agrees with
alarmed and the dismissive they all like
the idea of investing more resources
into the research for renewable energy
they all support a government subsidy
for those people who go out and buy more
fuel-efficient cars or install solar
panels on their roofs it doesn't matter
whether you're an alarmed or a
dismissive on climate change everybody
supports that policy and what that
suggests is that there are ways to talk
about this issue in particular because
it is ultimately an energy issue there
are ways to talk about it in in which
everybody can see that there's real
value the point is is that and this is
what politics is all about it's about
finding policies that people can come to
agreement about even though they may
agree to it for very different reasons
in the end we have to remember that the
climate system doesn't care whether
you're a Democrat or Republican or a
liberal or a conservative droughts don't
differentiate by your political party a
sea level rise doesn't care whether
you're Republican or Democrat a
hurricane won't make any distinctions
based on your
conservative or liberal ideology but in
the end we have to care we have to start
acting now to resolve this issue because
otherwise the impacts will affect all of
us
[Music]
the Yale School of Forestry Navarre mell
Studies is without a question one of the
most exciting places to be in this field
right now it's very rare to find a
school or even a department and another
University where you see such a
diversity of perspectives all brought
together under one roof ultimately
environmental problems require an
interdisciplinary approach no single
discipline can solve climate change
no single discipline can solve
biodiversity extinctions no single
discipline can create the sustainable
city and yet only in places like here do
all of those different perspectives come
together in an integrated and
interdisciplinary way to be able to
solve the real-world problems that we
face in the 21st century for more
information about the Yale School of
Forestry and environmental studies visit
environment yale.edu